our next guest played golf at the
University of Houston where he roomed
with much better golfers like Fred
Couples and Blaine McCallister he then
went on to become a prolific broadcaster
he's called some of the greatest moments
in sports history including several
memorable super hoods
by Sunday night's Patriots Rams games
he's known for his catchphrase hello
friend
we're very happy that we get to call him
one of our friends he's definitely the
only guest this week that's had the
dinettes in his house
[Music]
yeah you showed up you got the gold cart
there
feeling good okay so if I took thank you
let's say golf bag driver what to get to
your house from pebble anything from my
house not to the range here right here
in front from right here
I'd say it's inside 200 yards maybe oh
it is yeah if you're taking a direct
line yes okay so like a 5-iron for you
probably more like a 7-iron yeah yeah
but from my house to the 18th green
would be about maybe 250 you know so I'm
in between here and they're not trying
to give my coordinates I don't know if
it enters your mind but is there any
point where you go I live at Pebble be
everyday I mean it should know it's in
us with gratitude I mean I cannot start
my day without having a moment of
reflection I call it whatever you want
prayerful introspection I what start
every day with my thanks for being able
to have so many of the many blessings
that have come my way and that's
certainly one of them well you got a
great wife you had little two little
ones they're great older daughter yes
yes it's just it's and it's it's
beautiful we love living here
we made the decision eight years ago
that this is where we wanted to spend
our life and and have it as a base and
we're here full-time and it's not like
every week is the week that you're
experiencing right now yeah it is always
fun but it's much quieter than it is a
week of the AT&T Pebble Beach pro-am the
busiest week of the year now we have the
US Open coming in June that's gonna be
fun and I get to just experience it as a
fan people walking around outside the
gallery ropes and then just enjoying the
competition but the concore the car show
here is the biggest event of the year as
far as just pure volume of people the
Concord the elegance yeah it's a little
out of my I have no idea what that's all
about but it's an interesting watch it's
just people watching I love it any
fallout from us being at the house last
year a little third wife okay a little
bit
someone now I think it was Andrew posted
us videos now I know that you've you've
uh who posted the Hoopoe not in the
house not not in the houses par three
and which is fine oh my gosh I'm so
sorry no you're fine it's just you know
it's we've had a few people show up
unexpected analysis then because you
happen to pan to your right
oh no so you can see exactly where we
are it's okay my wife she'll get over
maybe in three or four years but no no
it's okay you're back we love you guys
maybe maybe that's why when I said to
Jim to come this Oh Dan we're gonna walk
in the house and it has one of those
left signs and baskets leave your cell
phone here when we walk in this air
you're fine McLovin is part of the
family we're fine with it
seriously oh I did is a good no it's not
I was trying to throw a a lame joke out
there we're fine okay yeah and I should
get pro flowers so much happens after
the Super Bowl because we always want to
rate how good it was the halftime show
the commercial got a pin you know and
all that of course it comes with the
turret or and then when I saw you
Tuesday when I first got here it
everybody was focusing on the ratings
like was this a good Super Bowl like we
want to process it right there and we
want to have an answer right there how
do you explain the viewership of start
this you know at the start of the Super
Bowl to the end of the Super Bowl
because you keep track on probably you
know 15 minute increments I mean I don't
I happen to see the numbers yeah III
like trying to crunch numbers and talk
ratings it's not what they they asked me
to do but you can't help there's so much
discussion about an interpretation comes
with it but the reality is I had a lot
of people say oh I saw the rating saws a
little bit down by the way it still is
the biggest show in television by a mile
but it what's interesting is when once I
glanced at it
the idea that because the game didn't
have a lot of offense that people were
tuning out is not true they the actual
the rating grew through the entire game
broadcast when the game started the
audience wasn't there it wasn't there
all afternoon even in the pregame run up
to four hours leading to it the the the
viewership was down whatever it was
10-15 percent so when we started the
game and again I'm just a guy just
looked at the numbers they don't ask me
to be their ratings guru we were doing a
thirty five rating in the first quarter
I'll just give you a little example of
how that's down our AFC championship
game
New England Kansas City which did a
monster rating which was the second
biggest AFC champion reading in 42 years
we had a bigger rating in the fourth
quarter and overtime of Kansas City New
England than we did the first quarter
and a half of the Super Bowl we had less
of an audience at the Super Bowl than we
did at the end of the AFC Championship
why you know I you tell me why it's not
that anyone knew there weren't going to
be a lot of fireworks on the field I
happen to enjoy a great defensive game
myself and Tony and I had a lot of fun
with it but I'm guessing the Patriots
fatigue I think and I don't think la has
embraced the rim and I don't think it's
LA by the way the of a rating for that
market was lower than the national
rating we did a lower rating in LA than
the rating for the game and again you're
talking fractions if whatever it was a
forty one one it did a 40 point eight in
in Los Angeles but I think that's more
to do with America just doesn't quite
know the Rams yet you know they don't
know that much about Jared Goff yet it
sounds inconceivable to us you know
we're fantasy football players were
football freaks we watch all the games
you know we know about Aaron Donnell how
great Todd Gurley is but I still think
it it just wasn't there yet as far as an
attraction and obviously they didn't
bring a lot of people travel wise as far
as a fan base to the game not that that
would affect the TV ratings but you know
it's a it's a growing thing in Los
Angeles they're gonna be super for a
long time with Sean McVeigh and with
golf and everybody else's in Tarrant
Donald but I just I think that was more
of that than anything else maybe a
little bit of Patriots fatigue I don't
know I
I have a hard time believing that but
I'm sure that people think otherwise
your opening line to Tony Romo yeah
welcome to this welcome Super Bowl they
had a great wines actually yeah yeah
yeah so I've been waiting for somebody
to say that my entire life he's a great
guy he's been an unbelievable teammate
we've enjoyed these two years it's just
my life's in a good spot now and and
having I mean you're lucky you get
fouled Oh mm-hmm and you get Romo and
then I get him in Grant Hill and Bill
Raftery coming up here with March
Madness yeah I'm good I'm really lined
up when did you know though and I
remember talking to somebody where Romo
they had heard about an audition and
said he's gonna be different than any
other analyst now this this was not CBS
okay but I was told it's different than
anybody who's gonna be on TV well he
didn't audition with anyone but us so
you may have we actually didn't even
audition he had the job before he'd even
put a head son yeah did you guys did
mock is a mock broadcast starting in May
of 2017 from the broadcast Center in a
little hole in a sound booth on the
second floor watching a game off of a
monitor not even half as big as this
monitor in front of your desk okay so
you're trying to call the game off of
something about that big and it was a it
was a broadcast that a game that I had
broadcast the previous year Carolina
against Oakland and so I kind of knew
where this game was going with the plays
were a Tony was not informed in advance
of what the game was gonna be so he
called it cold and it was really good I
mean he's he's definitely growing I
don't want to take away anything from
the effort the coaching from from a lot
of people involved in the process but
Tony has some natural instincts that are
just off the charts but you guys this is
the new summer on Madden well that's we
would strive for that that that's a
wonderful compliment and that but this
generation I think the dynamics actually
or a little similar in style because I
think and I'm take myself out of this
nobody
once Pat Summerall okay but I I do see
in in Tony I do see a a certain pizzazz
and entertainment value we haven't seen
since since John Madden III I got to
work with Pat for years so I worshipped
the guy I actually carried in my pocket
during the game of one of his sobriety
coins that his wife gave me after he
passed in April of 2013 and I wanted
just to have a presence I had it in my
pocket when I called Super Bowl 50 which
was my first Super Bowl since Pat had
passed and I just was thinking of him a
lot I had a picture card of Jack
Whittaker who called Super Bowl 1 my
heroes we've talked about in the past
how much I look up to these guys but as
far as Pat Summerall goes I for 10 years
got to be part of the CBS golf team with
Pat as the anchor yeah and and and you
know a lot of people are a business can
say oh hey I've worked with Pat
Summerall well you may have been at the
same network she didn't really work with
him and I'm saying he may have been on
the second crew or the third crew fourth
group you weren't calling games with him
as I didn't do in ml Cam's with Pat but
I did 20 golf events a year and for 10
years hundreds of dinners traveling all
over the country I got to work with him
and I got to pick his brain I got to be
around him just listen to the way told
the story and the presence he had so our
game on sunday marked 17 years to the
day since Pat Summerall 's last football
broadcast it was Pat and John Rams
Patriots in the Adam Vinatieri the first
of the six cool so I you know I kind of
have that in my heart that 17 years ago
to go today Pat and John called their
last game and you know we strive for
that Tony and I talked about that that's
kind of the model you say down the road
get enough reps if somebody we were
lucky enough to say that team as far as
a tandem reminds us of what that used to
be that that would be a tremendous
compliment
Jim Nantz joining us here on the
opposite end of the driving range here
good a good end here too
well they were trying to hit into a new
close oh yes Mickelson was trying to
I'll know question but Phil would do
that yeah he would think it was funny
you know but I'm trying to carve out a
career
well efz you're wearing his equipment
logo right there yeah
proudly I said kalalau so he's trying to
pound a few in here have they come
within ten ten yards of here uh they're
about forty yards but you can hear him
plopping down here this means he's
flying at about 300 this is my 340 from
here to where they are lactate back
there and that's uphill by the way it is
and you're getting no roll out here as
you can see nothing's bouncing in here
last time you played pebble
I played pebble first off I'm on pebble
everyday I'm home I take my son down to
nevels which is a little halfway house
if he will off the 10th tee and we get
one of those encrusted peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and a banana
he loves that that's a big father/son
moment we ride in the cart we go down
and see a lot of golfers along the way
stop watch some golf swings and we have
that experience virtually every day I'm
home as far as playing I don't play that
much
I really don't want my want my time to
be with my family
do you have all so much that I just
can't justify I wouldn't feel right
about it I mean I play occasionally but
I haven't I haven't played in several
months I'm gonna come home and I wanna I
just want to be around my kids and my
wife you know okay but you set me up
last year where I fell for this sob
story that you don't play and then we go
through the part three tournament and
then you won this is something about
natural talent you just can't be
sometimes it's just it's just gonna come
out you know when the moments there I I
hit one shot yesterday it's my first
golf swing of the year we had the Pebble
Beach pro-am million-dollar shot for
charity which is a program you can air
on the you know one of your comp
competitors including over the weekend
leading into our third round coverage
starting the day and it was a
hundred-yard shot and we had Darius was
there I mean everyone that's in the
celebrity field was there and at the end
after it all cleared out my wife and
kids were there and they said take take
a swing so I took my first swing of the
year in a reminded me a lot of the shot
in the backyard yeah because it was only
a hundred yards iris has calibrated with
the golf balls being you know a lot
taken off of those so it felt good
actually as I was over the shot I was
thinking of you I was thinking about
this big match today so is it my warmup
okay for it's a day and I'm hoping that
mclovin is gonna be there today again as
our to videotape that's fine well no you
I want you to film the competition so
you have to sign a release form shall we
go to someone's house to you do you ask
first can I you know do you mind if I
release no no his logic is he'll beg for
forgiveness
I say yeah you know so when he screws up
where is the begging he feels no no I
don't shoot him I don't want to know
what really happened to and I think it
may have been I'm not sure which came
first but Faldo and I had the whole CBS
crew up to the house maybe the night
before and found Oh made a hole in one
yeah and that happened the night before
so he made the although released it so
I'm just begging you want to know just
making me feel bad if nono Faldo did is
in fact as soon as and went in the cup I
turn around I thought Oh somebody's
gonna post this and I went over to his
friend and said before you she said it's
our two million hits later whatever it
was it was so no damage by the way I
don't know how am i coming to your house
by the way I don't know how to say this
indelicate terms but I'm not looking
forward to the next time you do the
Super Bowl because I'd liked some nice
touchdowns more than like a 1 yard or
two yard run this is an amazing thing
it's just whatever luck of the draw so
our last two Super Bowls the longest
touchdown that I've called two yard in
two cities go to Super Bowl 50 Paul look
it up all right Malik Jackson and fumble
recovery in the end zone Jonathan
Stewart Carolina dives over the top from
the one
and CJ Anderson from two yards out
clinched the game in the fourth quarter
last week we had Sonia Michelle from two
yards out so 0 1 2 and 2 yard touchdown
calls thank you very much thank you very
much and so we have a couple more years
before your next Super Bowl no it's that
they all are gifts when you get to do
let's face it oh did you ask me
originally we started out the eras pause
and think I mean you I hope you do you
guys do yes
you know what but it many people how
many of your friends would love to trade
out what you're doing we make fun of
them every day if we can on social so I
think when I handed out the Super Bowl
the first time in Tampa
after Steelers Cardinals Santonio Holmes
and then you're done
and I walked off that podium and I went
I'm from a town that used to be called a
village and I'm I just handed out this
Super Bowl trophy they they don't
remember you you know if you do it right
but if you screw up then they might
remember well there's always that in the
you know if you want to go there
mentally yes there's a lot to suffer
through and I walk down the steps
there's confetti the Steelers are doing
you know snowmen and I walked into the
NBC trailer and I sat down by myself no
one was in and I thought holy bleep I'd
I just handed out this and I didn't tell
my family no no they knew I was there
they didn't know I was handing out the
trophy I say they didn't know then
everybody's like they're going you're
handing out the superblock I'm like I
always loved that hey there I'm gonna
text your gym you're doing this - I know
it's it's a big thing and and the same
time you're being pushed along because
they want to get to the programming on
the bus I don't know that they're
talking yes you in your ear like alright
alright speed it up I had a quirky thing
happen at the AFC Championship game
after that thriller the 3731 overtime
win by the Patriots did it in the locker
room I had no audio so and then I had
the double headset kind of like what you
have now except the ear plug type I
couldn't hear a thing I couldn't hear
anything that Robert crap Bill Belichick
Tom Brady said I just shook my hand a
lot of [ __ ]
anything they said I had nothing and I
just tried yes how long this should go
on and they could have said anything you
know and and I would have just like Jim
Jim I hate you you don't Tony wanted all
right
let your wife know we're gonna be over
in a little bit oh there's no you are
welcome to come ok import to it ok for a
long time and this contest is not just
between us oh I know but only the good
ones are to take to confiscate that it's
my concert Jim I'm trying to do a promo
to say goodbye Jim will be on the call
this weekend for CBS the AT&T Pebble
Beach pro-am of course the Masters
coming up and the NC double-a tournament
and we will be posting the video of our
par 3 tournament oh boy coming up for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]